au milieu des mouches et des
congélateurs brisé béatrice pierre est
ce que sa vie chaque jour pour vendre du
poisson du atouts des moteurs pour nous
la volaille à pied noir tasser elle a vu
des véhicules filer à vive allure frappé
des clients et des marchands derrière
elle marché non achevée qui devait tout
changer
un projet gouvernemental de près de 20
millions de dollars abandonné depuis
deux ans la firme qui a décroché le
contrat soutient qu'elle n'a reçu que la
moitié des sommes prévues
ce projet ne serait qu'un des nombreux
exemples récents de la corruption en
haïti du détournement des sommes du
fonds petro caribe en vertu de ce fonds
le gouvernement haïtien et achetait du
pétrole vénézuélien à tarif préférentiel
il devait ensuite investir les économies
réalisées dans l'éducation la santé et
les infrastructures surfacturation
favoritisme détournement de fonds les
manifestants accusent les politiciens
d'avoir dilapidé près de 4 milliards de
dollars
le tout cas ib avait un vol il ya des
pillages c'est comme des pirates qui
attaquent en pleine mer un bateau
sa photo a fait le tour du monde le
cinéaste et activiste gilbert mirambeau
s'est servi des réseaux sociaux pour
réclamer des comptes
on a une dictature parlementaire on le
retrouve devant la cour supérieure des
comptes qui a publié un rapport sur les
malversations du fonds petrocaribe et
élément déclencheur de soulèvements
populaires
gilbert mirambeau affirme que pendant
des décennies les haïtiens n'osaient pas
dénoncer publiquement la corruption mais
que petro caribe est la goutte qui a
fait déborder le vase
on a eu les lettres rallier on a eu peur
on se cachait on a rien ici de la même
chose mais là on a un tournant un un
carrefour où on peut dire quelque chose
il ya plus de répression il ya plus
d'assassinats on peut dire quelque chose
et je pense que on a cette
responsabilité aussi bon nombre
d'opposants au président jouvenel moïse
espère la tenue d'un procès petro caribe
tel que promis par le premier ministre
c'est un adversaire politique du
président auguste d'aimer à lui n'y
croit pas le premier ministre
actuellement n'a pas les moyens de sa
politique
malheureusement pendant ce temps
béatrice pierre demande simplement qu'on
termine la construction du marché pour
enfin travailler en sécurité
il sut philippe leblanc radio-canada
port au prince